let's go next to our caller from the two
six seven area code who's calling today
from two six seven all right David can
you hear me yes I can who's this my name
is Tony Holland all right Billy all
right very good I wanted to talk about
reparations and how I just don't pretty
much agree or I'm not really hearing any
realistic I don't know if it's going
agree with the way that the conversation
is taking place even from you know my my
fellow black people mmm um so here's a
stance really quick we'll run down it's
all about slavery Jim Crow segregation
redlining
we all know those kinds of things that
were very well versed in how I what I
feel is that um white America has a
standard response for that which is we
are going to maintain the white
supremacist system that is in place by
saying that all of those people are dead
and we cannot be held responsible then I
just don't feel that as a community we
have formed a proper response to that so
for me I look at it economically black
people owned two percent of businesses
in the United States of America meaning
that almost 100 percent of us have to
leave our community to have access to a
single opportunity in this country
defining our largest issue the roof of
our issue is in fact labor dependent the
you know we have six about six and a
half million black men over two million
black women with felony convictions and
the statistics bear out that there is a
1/10 of a percent of a chance that ever
being gainfully employed again if you
are black with a felony conviction right
so my whole my whole thing is one I
don't support cash payments whatsoever
because there is no reason I just do not
see a successful path if you were to
give a bunch of people money who have no
financial
about themselves then it's just going to
be a waste of money so for that I agree
with okay but I support a comprehensive
reparations package that all that you
know similar to what marianne williamson
says I advocated at least two hundred
and fifty billion dollars paid and
twenty five billion dollar yearly
increments for the purposes of of
establishing and growing black owned
businesses and labor dependence by fifty
percent in a ten-year period yes so
listen basically I mean it sounds like
you and I are in a pretty similar page
so I this actually came up in my
conversation with Sam Harris about a
month ago where basically I think that a
focus on reparations in the Democratic
primary may be counterproductive to
ultimately getting someone to unseat
Trump as a merely practical matter that
being said I am very open to the way to
to doing reparations in a way that is
not just throwing cash at people because
that will help some people to some
degree but it's not going to change
really what we're trying to change at
its core so what what the idea that I
like and I am open to different ways of
doing it in terms of the numbers is to
spend the money in ways where we are
going to boost minority homeownership
we're going to boost minority
entrepreneurship we're going to fund
education and to start trying to level
out what are the remaining inequalities
of horrible historical realities in the
United States so it sounds like you and
I are sort of on similar pages at one
point I honestly take offense to are you
saying that you feel that basically
we'll lose and submit the election to
Donald Trump
if we actually for once in this country
try and represent represent black people
at the point of their most pressing me
you you could you could argue that I'm
wrong about it or that I'm yeah
I just feel like what is being presented
if people aren't really thinking outside
the box for me I don't see an issue with
the Democratic Party potentially losing
if they just Center their methods around
appealing for the rape let me make sure
I make sure I understand I want to make
sure I understand what you're saying
when you say you don't see an issue are
you saying you don't think Democrats
will lose or you don't care if they lose
by focusing I just want to make sure I'm
understanding what I think that is the
reality I think that that is the
expression go of fear of the people who
haven't really thought about it
beyond a typical talking point you're
right and I think here's the important
thing to keep in mind when I say I see
it as electorally risky the conversation
you and I are having and the way you and
I would go about this I don't think is
the risky conversation which is to deal
with things like homeownership and
education and entrepreneurship the
problem is that whenever it comes up the
conversation becomes one of how do you
decide who we give cash to and how much
do we give them and you and I both agree
it's the wrong conversation and I don't
see them having a conversation that's
different than that one that being said
if the conversation they have is the one
you're having I'm all for it I think we
need to reorient the discussion and get
away from the concept of cash payments
in general is that there's the single
biggest thing that holds us back I think
the second biggest thing is the
assumption that we cannot run on
reparations and win one of the one of
the things that that I keep in mind is
actually shopping a reparations package
to actually races and people that are
connected to hate groups such as the KKK
and what I would say to them was do you
want less black people working and your
place of employment do you want less
black children you know going to school
with your white children let me finish
before you before you say this and do
you go for your spot and do you want
less black people living in your
neighborhood well if you support a
comprehensive reparations package yes
what we will do is
what it will do is allow for the black
community to be self-sufficient and
they're going to most likely stay in
their area when a hundred percent of
them don't have to leave for
opportunities all right let me think
more about that part I've not given that
part thought I appreciate the call I do
want to get to a couple more people but
I you've you very well explained your
position and I appreciate it thank you
David I really appreciate your time you
have to do a fantastic show I came
across you a few months ago maybe about
three months ago and I don't agree with
everything you say but I it's just
everything about your presentation the
way you speak the way you present your
ideas appeals to me I have listened to
the young turks for five years never
became a contributor well I became a
contributor of yours within the first
week thank you appreciate it all right
very good good to hear from Tony from
Philly hope to hear from you again